fox news alert happening right now
thousands of new york city police
officers firefighters and city employees
are marching across the brooklyn bridge
in protest of the city's vaccine mandate
many are wearing their job t-shirts and
holding my body my choice signs as well
as the american flag
mayor de blasio has warned city workers
if they don't get the vaccine by friday
they will be put on unpaid leave and now
the cdc is planning to quote educate
those who are hesitant to get the shot
here's c-d-c director rachelle wolenski
we believe it is very important to get
these people vaccinated there is a plan
should these people not want to be
vaccinated towards education and
counseling to get people the information
they need so that they are feeling
comfortable in getting vaccinated
something about the phrase re-education
and get these people on board seems
pretty strikingly similar to a really
tragic chapter in our globe's history
look when i see those images of people
protesting i don't see vaccines of covet
19 being at the heart of the issue i see
public trust in our leaders as being the
heart of that issue and here's an
interesting fact emily the majority of
people who are refusing covenant 19
vaccinations actually have been
voluntarily vaccinated against mumps
measles rubella tetanus dpt i could dip
theory i could continue to go on you
have to ask yourself why and it is
because when it came to covet 19 our
public health leaders have lied and lied
rampantly actually saw last week the nih
shyly admitting the fact that actually
it had been lying to the public about
having funded gain of function research
the very kind of research in the wuhan
lab that could have resulted in the
origin to this pandemic they lied about
it now a lot of people may say well
vaccinations and the origin of the
pandemic those are two different issues
it's not when it comes to covet 19
public leaders including public health
leaders have given the public no reason
to trust them and i mark my words it is
only going to make the problem of public
trust even worse if you force people to
accept something that they don't
automatically trust on their own and i
say this as somebody who wishes that
more people were vaccinated i think the
people who are responsible for that
failure are actually the public health
leaders and the leaders of our
institutions who have been rampantly
lying at every step from the origin of
this pandemic to what to do about it and
that's what we need to own up to to fix
it and tommy on that note of public
elected officials and public leadership
it was they who designated first
responders firefighters and law
enforcement and health workers as the
heroes of the pandemic and all of a
sudden the tone has shifted mightily and
we have all the way up to our president
saying that we should be angry
condemning those who have chosen not to
be vaccinated or as vivid points out
simply resist the mandate even if they
themselves are vaccinated these men and
women are absolutely the backbone of our
society we know that they are heroes
every day and they are public servants
and yet now they are being cast aside
and vilified as public enemy number one
let's also juxtapose this to what we
just discussed in our first segment
illegal immigration we've got americans
law-abiding americans decent
hard-working americans who have been
going to work for two years during a
pandemic dealing with health risk safety
risks and doing it because they needed
to do their job to put food on the table
for their families those decent
law-abiding hard-working americans are
now being treated like criminals and you
have hundreds of thousands now well over
a million illegal immigrants who have
invaded into this country and they are
being treated like upstanding citizens
but i'd also like to say this when we
see this protest in brooklyn and we see
these workers standing up when i saw
those images nothing made me feel more
proud to be an american because i saw
americans of every color every shape
every size every gender and probably
every political affiliation standing
together in the name of freedom that's
american as it gets and i'm so proud of
my fellow americans for standing up amen
harris part of what is so troubling
is the notion of that again the
reprogramming in education where you are
automatically branded an enemy you are
automatically branded frankly a criminal
in some sectors if you dare to even
question if you dare to
to expect what we were promised in the
beginning which were exceptions and and
other alternatives and here it seems
that not only the encroachment has
happened it has thinned everything out
but now there's been an absolute
criminalization happening of these
people who are daring to question so one
thing that we talked about during the
commercial break kaylee was the fact
that across some sectors of the united
states the vaccine mandates actually are
working and we want to acknowledge that
i mean it's difficult to say exactly why
in some sectors we know that meat
packing plants were a place where cobit
was rampant we know that those areas and
jobs unseen often it was a problem
um so you you do have that and that's
what biden is talking about when he says
that that the problem is we don't know
what those numbers look like
because they're jobs unseen oftentimes
and so when we say oh well they're
popular well are we talking a small
percentage of people i mean what are we
talking about here because the ones who
are in the streets
walking out
the american flag and what it means in
this country and that is not to be
mandated to do the things that you know
that you can be counted on to do right
because you're essential workers police
officers first responders and all that
when we see that we see the big numbers
and so we wonder when biden's talking
about they're working how many numbers
are they working among okay that's one
thing the other is something that vivik
was pointing to
how do we get to the point where we can
change the messengers
because if the message has always been
and it was working with president trump
it was working and don't let anybody
fool you that we weren't almost up to a
million shots a day when president trump
was in office because we were so when
biden says two things that are wrong um
that he came up with a shot which i
think he walked that back pretty quickly
or somebody did on his behalf but he
also did not
you know he wasn't the first person to
get us to those big numbers to those big
highs close to a million and beyond
right so we know that the message was
not broken but the messengers have been
broken and what do messengers do when
they break they lie they obseculate
maybe we change the messengers at this
point maybe the public wants to hear
from some people that they can trust i
don't know it's just an idea
yeah right and vivek sort of pointed to
that as well that the erosion of trust
because of that lack of faith in the
message maybe we don't hear from from
whomever it is people i'll treat him
like voldemort i won't say his name but
he knows who he is don't conjure him um
and to the point you made in the last
block however governor desantis takes a
different approach and five thousand
dollars in sunny florida is probably
looking more and more amazing by the day
to the first responders law enforcement
and firefighters that uh should
absolutely be our primary and most
respected members of society absolutely
absolutely